the Joe Rogan experience I think you
guys know would be for the it was Elan
about about I think he said that the
chest he said something bad about Tesla
no no no he was actually defending he
was talking good about Tai cans about
Porsche tycoons and Elon said he was
very unimpressed with him but as he
reminded me with Mema somebody replied
with a meme of not a meme a real video
of Bill Gates jumping over a chair and
they said I don't know I I find him
impressive and Elon said yeah that's
pretty impressive
I love when tech CEOs of major companies
have the can be silly like that
but Elon is very silly he responds to
people on Twitter he gets silly he's
having fun having a good time this is
Bill Gates jumping over a chair that's a
pretty good jump for a nerd not bad what
do you mean for a nerd I hate that word
by the way I love nerd yeah too good
word no but you don't use it you don't
mean I don't mean it in a positive way
yeah yes I do okay well let me let me I
do often leave you often yeah yeah I
mean a guy who like is wearing glasses
with a [ __ ] sweater with a collared
shirt underneath it he looks like a nerd
so you use it positively in that let me
a silly kind of way but you don't think
of a nerd as somebody as an ideal of a
man or an idiot like wrong with nerds no
I just like my perspective is never like
that look I'm a nerd about a lot of
things I mean see now you're saying that
I'm a nerd about for sure no I I totally
I guess when I was speaking to and
that's relevant for our time is that
science is not admired in ways because
I've seen the alternative mission Soviet
Union the way people admire scientists
is the way they admire great athletes
great great creators of all kinds and
nerds sometimes diminishes that
in ways that it seems like a peculiar
quirk of a human being is just like its
it connects it to like you know going to
comic-con conventions kind of nerd verse
that's different that's a dork the dork
yeah so when you comic-con dork we've I
think we've gone over this recently dork
is rarely positive
Dorf is good if it's self-deprecating
car self a dork I'm such a [ __ ] dork
but it's very rare that dork is positive
whereas nerd is often positive nerd is
like guys a science nerd heavy heavy
science nerd like that's that's just a
fun way of saying someone's really smart
about a certain thing but I know what
you're saying yeah but I don't think the
way around that is to eliminate words or
even stop using certain words
I think the way around that is just to
appreciate people that are really great
at science yeah that's the way around
that it's not the words don't really
matter it's perceptions that matter no I
don't think necessarily that science has
a bad perception it just doesn't have a
glamorous enough perception how many
people can name Oscar winners that are
just really good at lying they're just
really good pretenders and we can name
them but how many people can name Nobel
Prize winners in science is very few
right exactly and I guess the thing I
was also speaking to and definitely keep
using the word and it doesn't oh I'm
gonna preventing words is uh I don't let
nerds tell me what to do and just see
there you go
no the the thing so that's actually the
point I was trying to make it wasn't his
nerd is synonymous with weak that I
always hated as a person who loves
fighting like I like the appreciate like
I like the fact that people are
complimenting sort of the into the
pursuit of your scientific curiosity
that is great but I just never liked it
it's the thing I've experienced in this
country is nerd as an image is seen as
weakness he's the kid that gets picked
on and I was it always annoyed me
because
to me intelligence and it turns annoyed
me nerds annoy me because they like lean
into it like most people I know are kind
of like don't work out much yeah corners
and in it and they kind of lean into
that idea
do you think they're leaning into that
because they were bullied by people who
work out a lot so they think of those
people work out is like I don't want to
get into their thing those people suck
they were always mean to me yeah
something like that you kind of create a
narrative where like jujitsu or fighting
it's like a brute thing just like you
talked about with Greek statues having
small penises mm-hmm you say all those
barbarians with their big penises yeah
that's what he's telling me this is the
professor is giving us a tour was
telling me I think you can be a noble
person and have a big penis whoa is it a
humble brag an analogy let people know
that's all right no I agree with you
that's what people don't want right we
don't want to go with a bigger dick than
you that's smart that's like the same
thing you don't want a guy with a woman
or a guy you don't want a woman who's
hot and smart you know if that was like
when people think of really beautiful
women they automatically assume that
woman's dumb and oftentimes that is not
the case sometimes people just have
awesome bone structure and if they you
know stimulated themselves in mentally
if they pursuit things if they had an
interest in certain scientific or you
know esoteric ideas and you
underestimated them you would be you've
feel really humiliated if a super smart
but super hot girl put you in your place
let you know not only am i hot but I'm
[ __ ] smarter than you stupid
[Applause]